for years on this show we've been
clear-eyed about the threat from china
under the current brutal authoritarian
regime china is our enemy the dictator
xi jinping has laid it out in multiple
speeches their aim is to be the world's
dominant superpower by 2049 the 100th
anniversary of their evil regime if you
want to know what a world dominated by
china would look like
just look at china today a dystopian
high-tech police state george orwell's
1984 except big brother is more powerful
and has more sophisticated systems for
controlling the people one-party rule no
democracy no dissent no freedom of
speech
genocide religious persecution forced
abortions and sterilization torture
those who are a threat to their regime
denounced and disappeared you think what
happens in china will stay in china
look what they did to hong kong with
astonishing speed ripping up the
agreement they signed with the uk and
imposing communist dictatorship
they're planning to invade taiwan
control the south china sea new ships
new missiles they're taking control of
countries across the world asia africa
right here on america's doorstep in the
caribbean building roads in jamaica
telecoms and belize giving computers to
school kids in the dominican republic
what the soviets did in the cuban
missile crisis is totally amateur in
comparison this chinese regime is about
a thousand times more menacing to
america than the soviet union never was
why because we made china rich our
stupid establishment handing them half
our economy in a couple of decades china
used the opportunity we gave them
to develop the technologies for world
domination and they're well on the way
just this week we were warned that china
is already ahead of us in artificial
intelligence 5g nearly catching us in
many other vital fields the useless
establishment chin strokers in
washington debate whether this will be a
new cold war we're already in it you
idiots
china declared war on us years ago and
they're winning
so what are we doing about it
unbelievably our establishment is still
helping china sucking up to them bowing
down before them
just last week it was reported that
apple's ceo tim cook
secretly inked a five-year
275 billion dollar deal with the chinese
government more components from chinese
suppliers deals with chinese software
firms collaborating on technology
j.p morgan's jamie dimon cravenly
apologized to the regime for making a
joke they didn't like scared to death he
might jeopardize his blood money
investments
goldman sachs sachs's pathetic ceo david
solomon bragging about his long-term
commitment to china
how he didn't want to get involved in
politics but doing business in china is
a political decision one that betrays
america the sick founder of hedge fund
bridgewater ray dalio making excuses for
genocide by saying it's just like being
a strict parent
and then there's disney another massive
u.s corporation betraying america
disney wouldn't exist without america
yet it's disgusting ceo bob cepek now
chooses to push the propaganda of
america's number one enemy
just like nbc their ceo jeff shell happy
to make money by airing next february's
winter olympics which the totally
corrupt international olympic committee
by the way should never have given china
in the first place
nbc rushed to cancel its olympic curling
coverage over a sex toy sponsorship but
torture and genocide oh that's fine
is it worth it jeff shell for your 16
million dollars is your 30 million
dollars worth at rachel maddow while you
rail against authoritarianism on your
show every night the blood money from
backing the world's most brutal
dictatorship stacks up in your bank
account
and how about china's sponsor airbnb
with its non-stop woke virtue signaling
suddenly silent on human rights abuse
when it can make some money off it
co-founder nathan blechazik saying we're
not here to promote american values what
an ignorant disrespectful scumbag it was
american values that enabled you to
start airbnb that enabled you to get
rich off airbnb
those american values you refused to
promote you'd be nothing without them i
am sick of these corporate fat cats
betraying america it is time to take
them on we need a new category of crime
economic treason
we need to prosecute these economic
traitors tim cook jamie dimon david
solomon ray dalio bob chapman jeff
schell nathan bacharzik and all the rest
if you do business with china you're
betraying america economic treason lock
them up
tell us what you think at steve hilton x
and at next nextrev fnc
stay with us much more up ahead hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else